we knew that if if we were to mess up
that was back to people dying again
we were in a very very dark dark place
and we got out of that
I can't think really of another major
peace process that's been brought to a
clear fruition
this anniversary shouldn't be a victory
lab we need to look forward
it's a rather ground Parliament building
for a rather dysfunctional government
sharing power doesn't come easily in a
divided Society but that doesn't
diminish the significance of a historic
compromise 25 years ago it largely
silenced the guns and bombs and utterly
transformed Northern Ireland
[Music]
it's the eve of Good Friday 1998.
politicians are negotiating inside a
choir of protestant and Catholic school
children singing outside
the future is yours and what we can do
today is get a future that gives you a
better chance of having a good life
the hurt you see me in the background
looking where are we to the left behind
you can just see the top of my hair
25 years later those school children are
adults reunited with the musician who
brought them to storm to reminisce with
us
I remember learning a song very quickly
and being on the bus lots of excitement
doesn't really know what to expect and
them got there and there was this big
you know loads of crowds and I bet you
know this is intimidating what's this
all about everybody else's reactions
telling me that these are these are
important people and something important
is happening here and
we've got our job to do in the day sing
smile and enjoy the day out and yeah
this I just remember
it's feeling special no one wanted to
leave at all I think because when you
some great thing had happened
uh Sheamus Marlin later said that to
hear the inside of the talks to hear the
children singing it is a defining moment
in a way because this was the future
calling upon them
[Music]
Bernard had endured 30 years of violence
three and a half thousand lives lost
but IRA and Loyalist sea spars had
facilitated peace talks
with the deadline for agreement fast
approaching the British and Irish Prime
Ministers arrived in Belfast for one
final push a day like today I mean it's
not a day for sort of sound bites really
um we can leave those at home but I feel
that I feel the hand of history on our
shoulder were there conversations you
were involved in that you've never
spoken about in in the run-up to the
agreement yeah there was quite a few
very private and difficult conversations
and really part of it was trying to
make sense of
the opposing narratives of why we had
reached this position and and then
trying to bridge the gap of trust that
there was
between those two opposing narratives
and two opposing factions and in that
the the engagement with the I mean
frankly the people of violence was it
was important
for the first time the British
government was engaging openly with
Irish Republicans the Irish government
holding meetings with loyalists it were
a good few there were there were sacred
and they were sacred there were
you know even very few of my officials
would have known that I had those those
meetings and in fact one of them was in
a venue and I still can't find a venue
myself why does a t-shirt disappear from
their own delegation to go and meet with
loyalists
um with great difficulty
much of the grind work had been done by
Mo mullum her no-nonsense approach
rather unconventional for a Northern
Ireland secretary most contribution was
was immense because she was a complete
culture shock and you know I mean for
those of us
who had lived through successive
very conservative looking very
conservative Big C and small C looking
men who who were secretaries of State
for Northern Ireland I mean you know a
lot of them decent vote but you know
they they were archetypal British
politicians and suddenly in steps Mo
um who was
the complete opposite it was that effort
to engage like it's
it's so we we've all seen a lot of
Secretary of States come and go and it
was hard to see someone that would come
in and
plunk the legs open the table and throw
the hairpiece off and bang the table and
kick doors and you know it was unusual
to say the least and the world's media
descended on Northern Ireland in
anticipation the deal was on then off
then hanging in the balance the last
sort of 24 36 hours apart from a wee bit
of Teddy enough that had to be done at
our end it was it was waiting for the
other Trimble that's my sort of
recollection and I don't say that in any
disparities in the way he had a a big
challenge
so it wasn't really until his death and
I saw a lot of the
the footage of the bottle within
unionism that I I realized that uh you
know he was up against it nationalist
leader Joan Hume had got Shin Fein to
the table David trimble's task to keep
the Ulster unionists there
did he realize the price he would pay
for reaching a compromise in the end
possibly possibly not uh he knew that it
was a big leap into the dark he was
taking a a step that had never been
taken before
uh but it was one that he felt had had
to be taken he knew that we needed an
and to the conflict that we had had and
this was the best deal that he could
obtain didn't give him everything that
he wanted it didn't give anybody
everything that they wanted but that's
the nature of negotiation and compromise
the deadline passed but in the small
hours of the morning President Clinton
intervened speaking to party leaders by
telephone
it was late afternoon when the
president's Pace Envoy convened a
plenary session with this be Northern
Ireland's Good Friday
I'm pleased to announce
that the two governments
and the political parties of Northern
Ireland have reached agreement
there are so few moments in politics
where you you are in a celebratory mood
so few moments that you remember those
and remember them for all of your life
and this was one of them perhaps
certainly
yeah the most the most joyful moment I
ever had in my time in office
after a 30-year winner of sectarian
violence
Northern Ireland today has the promise
of a springtime of peace
the agreement that has emerged from the
Northern Ireland peace talks
opens the way for the people there to
build a society
based on enduring peace
Justice
and equality
if you're objective of artist Unity can
be pursued politically as you decided on
the basis of the agreement
how can you ever justify the violence
that took place beforehand well let's
not talk about that David now
fact as it happened
it's over it's finished those who
pursued armed actions from the
Republican point of view felt they had
no alternative we provided an
alternative they embraced that
alternative the IRA went away
and I look on the out in the Falls Road
here and the Sun's shining and you know
and and people have gone about their
business I I think about it 30 years ago
we were in very very dark dark place in
the 1970s
and we got out of that
and David had a significant role to play
in getting us out of that
I pray to you of David and his legacy I
am exceedingly Pride yes
prisoners were released early and
terrorists agreed to decommission
weapons Northern Ireland would have its
own power sharing government and would
remain part of the UK until a majority
voted otherwise but that devolved
government has collapsed numerous times
and is currently mothballed over brexit
and its focus on the border how capable
are the political leaders of today of
grasping
the nuances of Northern Ireland and
helping to resolve it
the best thing for political leaders
today
is to remember if they think the piece
has been a good thing it only came about
because of leadership
it only came about because there were
leaders prepared to be unpopular even
with their own Grassroots constituency
or part of it and it only came about
because there were Leaders with the
creativity and the imagination to say
whatever the obstacles we're going to
find their way through and they found it
we were coming from a position where we
knew that if if we were to mess up if we
were to blow the opportunity which we
could have maybe nearly did several
times
that was back to people dying again
you know it was back to to murders and
shootings and and you could imagine and
they often thought about this imagine if
it had went wrong at half five on Good
Friday well what did that weekend been
like in the North
no it's in the hands of the people they
go to the polls next month North and
South of the Border they'll vote on this
plan to bring them peace
a lot can change in 25 years but perhaps
what needs to change most is the
agreement Itself by giving a veto to the
largest unionist party and the largest
nationalist party it rendered Middle
Ground votes of less value
so the mechanisms which underpinned Pace
have also been the cause of the
political paralysis
but the children who sang outside the
gates in 1998 still believe the Good
Friday agreement offers most hope for
future Generations
at my house we see everybody as equal
religion and politics are two different
things they don't come together and they
shouldn't come together
um I think that's very important
and if we don't set a good example you
know then
I think it's something that I definitely
pass on to my boys and my children you
spend a bit of time together and those
barriers come down no stereotypes change
the perspective their perception changes
and you just see each other as people
and kids just want to play together and
sing together and and have fun and once
they they're able to see
they enjoy having fun too it becomes a
wee and not a awesome name
and those prices of Europe are still
echoing at my head after all these years
one more time
again
[Music]
me
[Applause]